when Internet companies go down they go
down
Netscape eToys myspace Geocities flus
all gone without a trace so what's
different about Twitter welcome to Hari
Sabhas just two years ago people were
writing eulogies for Twitter has had no
private direction and was losing users
and advertisers and the fact they were
unable to cope with trolling really
destroy their credibility employees left
in a dozens claimed that was a very
toxic environment and if they didn't
leave by themselves they would have
plugin laid off anyways and amongst all
of this Twitter was trying to sell
themselves and it failed there as well
Wall Street public and the press were
all merciless against Twitter declaring
that it was the end of Twitter in fact
in a single weekend in February of 2016
over a million Twitter users tweeted
hashtag ripped Twitter but somehow as
all of this drama was unfolding things
started to change it all started Jack
Dorsey coming back as CEO and since then
star X employs users and advertisers
have all started to come back and
Twitter stock has surged from $14 to
over $4 and today has held down at $36
in July of 2019 twitter has been
destroying earning expectations and has
really made a miraculous and unexpected
comeback Twitter is the first social
media company to lose a lot of their
users and then grow again in a
meaningful way so what changed twitter
has always tried to become a social
media giant very similar to Facebook
they offer a strikingly similar
experience and this has placed split the
population they have really tried to
create a major rivalry like Pepsi and
Coke or Airbus and Boeing but clearly
that was not working so they took a step
back and took a hard look at why users
were actually using Twitter and they
identified News as a big proportion of
their traffic and in April of 2016 to
remove themselves from a social media
section to the news section in the iOS
App Store and it wasn't just an identity
change they were actually becoming more
of a news discussion board they started
to stream local news broadcast
promote new stories on the timeline and
this has really increased the traffic
that we're sensors advertisers and this
has made advertisers very happy they
have completely cut out distractions and
put hundred million dollar projects to
his side like tell apart which they paid
four hundred and seventy nine million
dollars for they shut down a vine which
they bought for thirty million dollars
and they sold a fabric to Google Twitter
itself has admitted that they were doing
too many things and not doing any of
them very well and this new focus on
News has really given them a purpose and
allowed them to move forward twitter has
also been making an aggressive push into
premium live video they started this
venture with the ten million dollar deal
with the NFL they were able to stream
2016 Thursday Night Football on Twitter
and since then they had made a slew of
deals that has allowed them to stream
every single minute of every single day
and often even more than one at one time
and these streams are really renewed
interest in Twitter advertisers have
become much more interested in Twitter
as there has been a lot more traffic
coming to Twitter as a result ad rates
have significantly gone up for Twitter
in fact video has become such a
significant portion of Twitter that in
January 2018 ninety percent of all of
tour spending was for video in the past
year they have made over thirty deals
with companies like ESPN
Live Nation and BuzzFeed news and these
are booths turn to payback
Aaron Goldman the chief marketing
officer of foresee insights which is the
company that provides Twitter with
advertising said that forces clients ran
more than 1 billion dollars worth of ads
to Twitter in 2017 video has really
played a huge role and tourists come
back and they have realized this as well
this is why they have given so much
importance to video as it is their
largest form of revenue twitter has
become very serious about the issues of
abuse harassment threats throughout its
platform the product team has introduced
a new algorithm
modified the timeline and increased a
maximum character count to 280
characters from 140 characters these
changes have resulted in major user
backlashes
and severe negative criticism but with
time these changes have Ashley
La Puerta attract more new and casual
users since the introduction of the new
algorithm in 2017 they have really been
cracking down on abuse and harassment
they have been constantly iterating anti
harassment features at an unprecedented
pace they have begun to collapse tweets
that they think are abusive they built
an anti abuse filters into their search
they have large users to mute accounts
who haven't verified their account using
their phone number or email address you
can even mute users simply on the basis
that someone is using the default
profile picture Daventry smooth filters
are applied to specific words and of
course they have killed the default
profile picture of eggs which has pretty
much become synonymous with Falls and
they have stepped up the consequences
for serial abusers and hate groups since
February of 2017 even gone as far as
removing verification badges from white
supremacists harassment and abuse still
exists but the matter is nowhere close
to what once used to be and these
changes have really convinced many
people to give Twitter another chance
twitter has also gotten Lockean
benefited from many factors that were
out of their control their strong stock
performance has coincided with the
global bull market this is when the
stock market as a whole is doing really
well and as a result people are more
likely to buy pushing up stock prices
and the decision to switch to a news
industry followed Facebook's decision to
pull back after several scandals and
this was right after all the tension for
snapchat IPO had just died down on top
of all of this
Twitter's move to news industry
perfectly coincided with the 2016
presidential election and brexit and how
perfect is it that to this day Donald
Trump uses Twitter to provide updates on
a daily basis now
analysts really aren't that fond of
Twitter's talk as I think that it is
overvalued and has a lot to do with
speculation Twitter's talk price is 25
times as earnings before taxes interest
depreciation and amortisation now to put
this in perspective
alphabets as 14 times and Facebook's
only half of that a 12.5 times however
according to the same analysts too
as one of the most important things in
the stock market which is momentum so
after all of this how are they doing
today well they're destroying Ernie
expectations during the first quarter of
2011 ooh that was 18% higher than the
same period last year the revenue has
increased a 787 million dollars and
video ads has made up the bulk of that
increase Twitter's monetizable daily
active users has increased to 134
million people they experienced a 12%
increase in this number in just the
first quarter 20 and the company is
profitable with its earnings increasing
200% up to 191 million dollars not
everyone but most people are pleased
with how twitter has cracked down on
abuse and harassment today they take
down 2.5 times more tweets that share
personal information and 38% more
abusive tweets are taking down every
single week and these deleted tweets are
being used for machine learning making
the algorithm better every single day
and something else will attract your
advertisers onto Twitter is that it's
not just a platform to advertise but
Twitter also provides a prizes with data
insight more like Google and after all
of this Twitter stock is still jumpy and
it's not really clear if it's going to
be going up or down next but either way
it is doing exponentially better than
how it was just a couple of years ago
Twitter has been one of the biggest
social media giants over the past decade
however its pursuit to become more like
Facebook and harassment issues have
really reduced its user base people have
simply had no reason to use Twitter when
it was so similar to Facebook but worse
and these problems are really escalated
with the rise of new social media
platforms like Instagram and snapchat
but with the new focus on news and video
and a bit of luck and reduced abuse
twitter is definitely making a comeback
and in a couple of years they may be
able to grow to or even beat their peak
but that's all I have for you guys on
Twitter make sure comment down below
what company you would like me to cover
next also if you guys liked this video
make up a like and consider subscribing
if let's see more videos just like this
one but until then I'm Ari
I'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]